bom resumindo assim você acorda de manhã
toda animada e vai conhecer uma escola
onde está pensando em matricular seus
dois filhos
nesse dia especial era uma escola com
uma fama de ser super humana é até meio
criticada por ser a alternativa demais
chegando lá você conhece a coordenadora
uma pessoa tem um jeito superdoce uma
fala mansa aquela pessoa que
cumprimentei assegurando você assim as
duas mãos e ela vai te conduzido pelo
lugar e se mostra cada cantinho cada sua
linha de desenho ela mostra que sua
filha de 2 anos estaria fazendo naquele
momento ela mostra turminha que seria do
seu filho de 3 anos se fica
completamente encantada
para arrematar ela ainda faz um discurso
sobre a importância da diversidade e da
atenção individual na escola porque
nenhum ser humano igual ao outro e é
muito importante que as pessoas aprendam
isso desde pequenininho
neste momento já estava quase morrendo
em casa buscando as crianças perguntam
se já podiam começar já né
mas eu tinha que perguntar mas e aí vaga
tem não tem como é que é ela olha na
planilha e fala não super tranquilo tem
vaga para o ano que vem sim talvez o seu
mais velho tem que entrar numa fila de
espera
mas o sempre tem família que muda de
cidade família que muda de escola pela
minha experiência eu vou te dizer que as
vagas para seus filhos são garantias é
que eu faço a minha grande revelação que
o meu filho de 3 anos tem síndrome de
down e é exatamente isso que sempre
acontece
um silêncio constrangedor como era a
primeira vez que eu passava por essa
situação eu já sabia exatamente que esse
silêncio significava e exatamente as
explicações que viriam a seguir sempre
começa com veja bem
então veja bem olha nós somos uma escola
super aberta inclusive temos vários
alunos especiais
ai semana scott-heron sobe 2
temos vários alunos especiais mas você
precisa entender que as vagas são mais
limitadas
é essa e cipó atendimento tem que ser
mais especializado talvez haja um
acréscimo na mensalidade ea gente
precisa conhecer o seu filho antes de
aceitar a matrícula
como estava apaixonada pelo lugar porque
não tinha problema nenhum não tem
problema ele fala é que dia eu posso
trazer meu filho pra vocês conhecerem
aí ela fala ó faz assim eu vou falar com
a coordenadora de inclusão que ainda não
chegou ela chega sempre mais tarde e te
ligo te ligo no fim do dia já acendeu
uma luz vermelha né porque o turno da
manhã das 8 ao meio-dia ea diretora de
inclusão pela qual os pais pagam a mais
em cada chegadas das leia tudo bem vou
embora quando chega o fim do dia eu
recebi a ligação
ela também começa com veja bem e pela
fala acelerada da coordenadora já sabe
exatamente o quê ea quem seria dito ela
fala não então eu tenho uma nova olhada
aqui é o seguinte não tem mais vaga nem
por seu filho de 3 anos e um filho de
dois muito obrigada
lembro que estava passando as compras no
supermercado sair largando tudo e deu um
grito com ela a caixa tomou um susto
assim não tem vaga
assim de manhã tinha era garantido e
agora não tem mais pra pequena era
certeza não tem sorteio não tem fila de
espera não tem nada a não desculpa
desculpa foi um grande equívoco e
desliga o telefone
então vamos lá tristeza número um é que
não me deram nem a chance de apresentar
o meu filho de três anos que além de ser
uma criança muito muito fácil de lidar
muito tranquila
reconhece e fala todas as vogais uma
certa dificuldade para a letra é que
ainda não consegue mais tenta e entende
bem o conceito de contar de um a dez
metros e seu número dois é para
disfarçar não aceitação do mateus de
três anos a escola simplesmente
não estava aceitando a helena de dois
óbitos que era vergonha de dizer a gente
que ela mas não quer ele então assim de
repente a minha filha de dois anos super
esperta super carinhosa e só se comunica
na base do consenso por favor e obrigado
também não tinha de estudar eu não tô
aqui pra ficar me gabando e falando que
os filhos são capazes de fazer
eu só acho tudo isso uma grande perda
uma grande perda pra mim que entristeço
a cada ligação dessas uma perda para os
meus filhos que for preciso botar eles
em alguma escola uma perda pra
professores e coleguinhas e potencial
que perdem a chance de conviver com duas
crianças maravilhosas ea gente sabe que
não são só as minhas duas e uma grande
perda para milhares de mães
eu sei que passou por isso todos os dias
quando a gente fala aquela frase que tem
coisas que o dinheiro não compra a gente
sempre pensa em amor saúde momentos
especiais
mas eu vou dizer pra vocês que vaga na
maioria das escolas o dinheiro também
não compra não é preciso um caminhão de
dinheiro mas também do número certo de
cromossomos
esse capítulo da nossa história tem um
final feliz
depois de rodar e passar com situações
semelhantes muitas vezes a gente
encontrou uma escola onde os dois
estudam hoje e onde estamos muito
felizes onde eu encontro professores
abertos a conversar abertos aprender e
que sempre vem super orgulhosos me
contado os avanços do mateus e nem tão
orgulhosos assim das bagunças da helena
infelizmente essa escola só tem ensino
infantil
então daqui a três anos a nossa saga
continua mas eu já criei uma estratégia
pra daqui a três anos
eu não vou sozinha eu não vou mais
precisar se as escolas sozinha eu vou
levar comigo
uma turma de 25 pessoas eu arranjei 25
stolen sabe eu vou levar comigo os nomes
desses 25 jovens que hoje cursam ou
acabaram se formar no ensino superior
que tem síndrome de down
mas um dia já tiveram três anos e
precisaram começar em algum lugar
obrigado